JERZY FORYCIARZ: Hello, Next.
Welcome to our
breakout session, where
we'll talk about the six
incredibly powerful GKE
capabilities you
may have missed.
It's a fun session packed
with cutting-edge tech
and a demo of our
newest capabilities.
My name is Jerzy.
And today with me is Roman.
Both of us are product managers
on Google Kubernetes Engine
team.
Together, we will learn
how using GKE and adopting
the right culture can
help customers like Ubie,
a Japan-based health
care technology startup
that automatically generates
medical records using
an AI-powered patient
questionnaire app,
achieve 20% saving
while deploying
to hundreds of
medical institutions
and improving availability.
Or Scoopwhoop, a media platform
for whom autoscaling on GKE
helps match capacity with
the real-time demand.
The result is 99%
uptime and 50% reduction
in infrastructure costs, while
removing operational burdens.
Now they can invest more
time on coding and less
on managing the resources.
As well as Mr. Cooper, an
industry-leading mortgage
service provider that now can
pack their nodes to achieve 90%
CPU load.
In fact, Forrester
conducted a study
in which they created a
composite organization based
on the GKE customers
and concluded
the following total economic
impact numbers of GKE
with expected investment
payback in under six
months for a typical customer.
Check their study to learn more.
Over to Roman.
ROMAN ARCEA: Thank you, Jerzy.
This is great.
Our team was on a critical
mission, a mission
to empower you,
the user, to never
again waste time and money
on infrastructure you
don't actually use.
When you run workloads on
Google Kubernetes Engine,
we know you've made
the choice in favor
of simplicity, efficiency,
security, and scalability.
But we also know that falling
for the non-efficiency pitfalls
is easy when you are in charge
of running infrastructure
at scale, with its endless
number of components
and possibilities.
In six years of
GKE's existence, we
learned that four major
challenges make your life hard.
The first challenge is cultural.
Many teams that embrace the
public cloud aren't used
to the pay-as-you-go
billing style and frequently
don't fully understand the
environment their apps are
running on, in this
case Kubernetes.
The FinOps movement, which
is getting lots of attention
recently, is all about
evolving such a culture.
One of the FinOps
best practices is
to provide teams with
real-time information
about their spending and
their business impact.
Small things like this
have considerable impact
on companies' culture, resulting
in a more balanced cost
optimization equation.
The second challenge
has been packing.
How well do you
pack applications
onto your Kubernetes nodes.
The better you pack apps onto
nodes, the more you save.
Then we have the
app rightsizing,
the ability to set appropriate
resource requests and autoscale
applications deployed
in the cluster.
The more precisely you set
resources on your pods,
the more reliably your
applications will run,
and in the vast majority
of cases, the more space
you'll save in the cluster.
And the last challenge is
node scaling down your cluster
during off-peak hours.
Ideally, to save money
during low-demand periods,
for example at
night, your cluster
should be able to scale down
following the actual demand.
However, in some
cases, scaling down
doesn't happen as
expected due to workloads
or cluster configurations
that block cluster autoscaler.
By themselves, each
of those are tricky.
But together, this
is a complex problem.
In our experience, most of
our provisioned environments
have at least two of the
following challenges at hand.
But fear not.
We're here to help.
Let's look at some of the
incredibly powerful GKE
capabilities you
might have missed
that will take you a step closer
to running GKE at scale cost
effectively.
Jerzy, over to you.
And tell us about your
favorite top three.
JERZY FORYCIARZ:
Thank you, Roman.
I certainly have
my own top three.
Let me focus on some of the
existing top-of-the-line GKE
capabilities.
And here there are.
Autopilot.
Traditional Kubernetes
expects you, the user,
to understand and manage the
control plane, worker node,
security configuration, upgrade,
scaling, and availability.
GKE, on the other hand,
is a truly managed service
that helps you focus
on your business.
The best and most intelligent
way of using Kubernetes today
is by activating GKE Autopilot,
a mode of operation that
automatically manages
the most complex aspects
of your infrastructure
configuration.
If, however, the user needs
more control of their clusters,
she can choose a standard
GKE mode of operation.
You can think of modes of GKE as
the level of control customers
have over a given GKE cluster.
And the best part yet?
You can mix and match
modes of operation
between different clusters.
So you choose GKE Standard
for advanced configuration,
flexibility over the
cluster infrastructure,
or GKE Autopilot to
have Google provision
and manage entire
underlying infrastructure.
User is in full control
and can break glass,
converting Autopilot
clusters into Standard.
These are just a few examples
of how Autopilot does things
differently.
Autopilot clearly wins as a
hands-off Kubernetes experience
because it optimizes for
production like Kubernetes
expert, provides strong
security posture,
lets Google become your SRE,
reducing the day-2 operation,
improves resource
efficiency, and it's still
Kubernetes, still GKE.
But how does this all play
into GKE cost optimization?
GKE Autopilot shares a
four-way scalability capability
with the GKE Standard.
Same, well-known tech as
horizontal pod autoscaling
or vertical pod
autoscaling apply and serve
as a frame of cost reference.
Users are still in full control
about how their workloads will
scale and behave.
However, the
infrastructure is now
managed fully by the Autopilot.
And that has significant
optimization implications
for everything you
plan to do with GKE.
You remember early
in the conversation,
we talked about the
four main challenges
of cost optimization.
With Autopilot, you pay for the
compute resources requested.
With our new pay-per-pod
model, paying for nodes
remains a thing of the past.
That means that bin packing
is not a problem anymore.
How cool is that?
Not only do you get a
managed hands-off experience
that lets you focus
on your business
while improving your security
and operational posture,
you also get rid of one of
the most challenging aspects
of cost optimization.
And if you thought
this is not enough, how
about not having to pay for
the compute overhead costs
of running the OS and the
cost of running Kubernetes,
such as Kube system components?
Scalability is a big subject.
We graduated 15k to
GA in 2021, which,
for the vast majority of
users, removed scalability
as a constraint
in cluster design.
Why does it matter?
Thanks to operating
in one large cluster,
you can simplify microservices
lifecycle management,
easier absorb larger
spikes in resource demand,
and shorten the time to process
data for batch workloads.
As the result, you can
combine the services
of your organization into one
or just a few GKE clusters that
provide better utilization
and, in effect, will cost less.
Combine this with
our cost optimized
machine types such
as E2 or Tau for even
better price/performance ratio
compared to general purpose
VMs.
Next is the node
auto-provisioning,
a feature that is internally
powering all of Autopilot.
But what if you can't
yet run Autopilot?
Bin packing, that
annoying issue that
requires you to either make
sure your workload fits well
inside of the machine side
or manually create and manage
multiple node pools and play
with affinity, that can quickly
get out of control and become
an operational bottleneck.
But there is a simple option--
configure node
auto-provisioning.
Node auto-provisioning is the
next generation of our cluster
autoscaler that not only knows
to scale your cluster using
the chosen VM types, but also
knows to create entire node
pools from scratch
that are best suited
for your specific workloads.
Node auto-provisioning makes
GKE clusters fully automatic,
provisioning relevant machine
types like GPUs and TPUs,
and removing node
pools when not needed.
Node auto-provisioning is also
integrated with vertical pod
autoscaling and provisions
optimal node pools
ahead of vertical pod
autoscaling updates
to ensure quick action.
In practice, that
means that you're
more likely to have VMs
that are the right size
for your workloads
than what you get
with the manual provisioning.
All right, Roman.
Those are my top three.
What about yours?
ROMAN ARCEA: Thank you, Jerzy.
I definitely have
my own list as well.
Let me go through some
of our latest additions
that we believe are
important for everyone
to know and understand.
We know that with Autopilot
and node auto-provisioning,
bin packing is a nonexistent
or considerably smaller
of a problem.
But what about
application rightsizing?
While app rightsizing is
a challenging dimension
to tackle, we've been
making significant progress
to make it simpler for you.
Let's look at the latest preview
for the multidimensional pod
autoscaling.
Horizontal pod
autoscaler is a term
that is familiar to
most everyone using GKE.
Horizontal pod autoscaling
scales your pods horizontally,
adding replicas when certain
thresholds or conditions are
met.
HPA works hand-in-hand
with cluster autoscaler
or node auto-provisioner,
making sure
that resources
requested by containers
can be accommodated
on an existing node.
If this is not the
case, new nodes
are being added
to the node pool.
However, that means that the
user deploying containers
must have expert knowledge of
the exact amount of resources
to be configured
for their workloads.
Based on what we know of
how Kubernetes is used,
the right resource choice is a
true challenge that few master.
This is why we've
introduced the vertical pod
autoscaling, a capability that
understands the true resource
usage of your containers
and recommends
or directly adjust the
requests to get them
as close as possible to what
your containers actually
need to operate properly.
However, HPA and VPA did not
always play well together.
As HPA had targets
such as CPU, VPA
had trouble understanding either
resources under consumption
was a choice or an effect.
This is why we've introduced
the multidimensional pod
autoscaler, now in preview.
With a single
object, GKE can now
manage both horizontal
and vertical autoscaling.
While HPA continues to add
or remove pod replicas based
on CPU, vertical pod
autoscaling works
on memory, one of the most
over-provisioned resources,
to adjust it to requests
that meet best your container
actual usage needs, with this
further simplifying the app
rightsizing and
the off-peak hour
over-provisioning challenges.
Now, what if we told you that
you could improve your GKE
cluster utilization meaningfully
with a single change?
Please meet the
optimize-utilization profile,
now in GA.
If your applications
are ready to tolerate
a more aggressive cluster
autoscaler behavior,
this is the feature to try.
The optimize-utilization
profile is the second
in line of our autoscaling
profiles giving users
choice of a more active
autoscaling and scheduling
behavior.
The well-known balanced profile
optimizes for availability.
It scales down idle nodes
only after 10 minutes.
Workloads are also spread
as much as possible
by the scheduler.
Optimize-utilization
profile, on the other hand,
strikes a balance between
availability and cost
efficiency.
Nodes scale down after
1 minute of being idle.
Aside, scheduler
tries to bin pack pods
from different deployments as
much as possible to add scaling
down speed and
statistically maximize
your chances of having
empty nodes that
can be easily removed.
Where it takes the balanced
profile as much as 10
to 30 minutes to
scale down nodes
after an abrupt
stop in requests,
it takes optimize-utilization
profile 1 to 3 minutes
to achieve the same result.
The way this is
achieved is reducing
a number of intervals
and thresholds
that increase the sensitivity
of autoscaling behavior
to set load thresholds,
such as scale-down times,
delay after add,
and scan intervals.
In our tests,
optimize-utilization profile
shows up as being one
of the capabilities
that you could adopt
for significantly
improved outcomes.
We've now had a look at
five great GKE features that
help improve the balance
between cost and performance out
of the box.
But how do you even know if
anything needs to be improved?
And what is the scale of
the opportunity at hand?
How do you help your
team take a step forward
into solving for the cultural
challenges of GKE cost
optimization?
I am thrilled to introduce
the GKE cost optimization
insights, now
available in preview
across all regions
and GKE cluster types.
GKE cost optimization insights
gives you a single entry point
into the GKE cost
optimization journey right
inside the user interface.
Let's see how it works.
Let's start with a blank project
and create the first cluster.
For this, we will use
the recently released
cost-optimized
cluster setup guide.
The setup guide helps build
a GKE standard cluster
with all the best infrastructure
level cost optimization
features built right in.
The cluster is now created.
But how do we know where we
stand on the cluster resource
usage efficiency?
With the new Cost Optimization
tab, discovering this
becomes a no-brainer.
In one click, we see
all the key information
for the clusters such as used,
requested, or allocatable
resources for memory and CPU.
Cost optimization insights works
across Standard and Autopilot,
should you have one or
hundreds of clusters.
Let's add a number of other
clusters to see it better.
Now, bin packing
is not a challenge
when you use Autopilot.
This is made very
clear in the view,
differentiating the
Standard and Autopilot
clusters on the type of
metrics you should care about.
In an Autopilot
cluster, only the
used and requested
resources matter,
while with Standard
you should also
care about your
allocatable capacity.
Spotting your cost optimization
opportunities out of the box
has never been easier.
And with the time
picker, you can even
see the data across the
time horizon of your choice.
CPU and memory
aggregations in time
gives you visibility
of your cluster sizes
and running capacity
at all times.
Cluster insights helps
spot bin packing,
app rightsizing, and potentially
off-peak hour optimization
opportunities.
But which of the workloads
are the largest contributors
to resource consumption?
To help answer
this, you have now
access to cost optimization
insights at workload level 2.
Let's deploy a number of
workloads to various clusters
to see this in action.
There are now multiple
deployments available.
Let's also top it off
with one of the offerings
from the marketplace.
As everything is deployed
now, within moments
we start seeing
insights for workloads,
such as used, requested,
and resource limits
for each individual deployment.
With this new view,
understanding application
rightsizing opportunities
becomes considerably less
of a challenge.
By looking at used versus
requested capacity,
all teams can keep an eye on
optimization opportunities
for their individual workloads.
And that in turn helps with one
more cost optimization aspect--
building a solid cost
optimization culture
across your entire team.
Watch this space.
We're just getting started.
And we're looking forward to
adding more capabilities that
will improve visibility
and provide recommendations
for GKE cost optimization.
That was it from my side, Jerzy.
Take it from here.
JERZY FORYCIARZ:
Thank you, Roman.
And big thanks to our audience
for staying with us today.
And remember, we're on a
mission to empower you to never
again waste time and money
on infrastructure you
don't actually use.
So here's our call to action.
If you're only getting
started with GKE,
check Forrester
Total Economic Impact
Report to see what impact GKE
may have for your business.
Are you already deployed
and going full speed?
Follow these six things
we discussed today
and see how this advances
your GKE capabilities.
Have you already
done all of this?
Come partner with us for
more in-depth collaboration.
Get in touch with your
account representative
or reach us via media channels.
If you want to learn more
about GKE cost optimization,
follow these links.
Thank you.